droht der hilfe für die ukraine der
ermüdungsbruch ein ende des krieges ist
nicht absehbar möglicherweise kommen die
größten schrecken erst noch schon mehren
sich stimmen das massive militärische
engagement im ukraine krieg zu
überdenken geht dem westlichen
widerstand gegen den aggressor putin die
puste aus weil der krieg auch im westen
immer mehr zu spüren ist
uneingeschränkte solidarität der westen
und der ukraine krieg jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist natalia
branitz k sie sind aktivistinnen und
politikwissenschaftlerin stammen aus der
ukraine sind
mitbegründerinnen der allianz
ukrainische organisationen die kümmert
sich einerseits um humanitäre hilfe für
geflüchtete ukraine und andererseits um
die sichtbarmachung ihres landes gerade
hier in deutschland gustav dressel ist
bei uns er ist experte für
sicherheitspolitik militär strategien
und internationale beziehungen von einem
think tank also eine organisation die
sich über strategien gedanken macht
namens european council on foreign
relations also europäischer rat für
auswärtige beziehungen zugeschaltet sind
rüdiger lüdeking diplomat im ruhestand
und unter anderem ehemaliger deutscher
botschafter bei der osze der
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa und schließlich
mein kollege elmar theveßen leiter des
zdf studios in washington
liebe zuschauer live zuschauer wir
hatten für diese phoenix runde auch ein
mitglied des deutsch russischen forums
einen angefragt und um auch die position
in der sendung zu haben die auch
weiterhin für eine deutsch-russische
verständigung trotz des überfalls auf
die ukraine eintritt erst kam die zusage
dann heute nachmittag kurzfristig die
absage
glauben die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
eigentlich an die uneingeschränkte hilfe
so wie es ja auch in den titel haben der
sendung an die uneingeschränkte hilfe
für irland bis zu einem sieg reichen
ende des krieges
vielen dank für die einladung ich freue
mich sehr über das thema heute zu
sprechen
wir glauben daran dass wir durch das
zusammenhalten
wenn die hilfe aus der europäischen
union aus den westlichen ländern aus
großbritannien aus den usa zudem sieht
der ukraine kommen können gemeinsam wenn
wir zusammenhalten und wenn wir wirklich
das ziel vor augen auch sehr
ungeschickte hilfe des westens für die
ukraine glauben sie daran dass das bis
zum sag mal siegreichen ende eines
krieges
dass der westen sich auf diese zusagen
einhält
dass der respekt ja zu sagen ja die
jetzt an die ukraine gegeben ich hoffe
sehr darauf ich glaube das ist die
einzige möglichkeit dass ihr dann
gewinnen können wenn der westen auf
zusammenhalt immer thesen ein artikel in
der new york times
der hat jetzt aufhorchen lassen credo
dieses artikels ist ein starkes
engagement in der ukraine ein
langandauernder militärischer beistand
das sei nicht im interesse der usa berge
auch die gefahr einer eskalation in sich
was man da gelesen hatte die new york
times möglicherweise die berühmteste
zeitung auf der ganzen welt war das eine
einzelmeinung oder ist das so ein breit
gefächertes friendly fire in den rücken
des us präsidenten der eine ganz andere
position vertritt
nein ich glaube nicht mehr diskutiert
natürlich hier in den usa wie
anderenorts auch und in diesem fall war
das ein artikel des editorial boards
also der herausgeber die im grunde um
noch einmal klar gemacht haben amerika
darf nicht teil eines krieges gegen
russland werden und zwar unmittelbar das
heißt davor gewarnt hat sich so in den
krieg hineinziehen zu lassen dass man
nachher sich russland direkt als gegner
gegenübersteht und das ist eine leser
hat die eigentlich von allen geteilt
wird allerdings gibt es ein paar
mahnende stimmen die ich schon sagen
dass man bereit sein muss auch
kompromisse zu machen um einen ausgang
zu finden aus diesem krieg vielleicht am
berühmtesten gerade henry kissinger
heute auf dem weltwirtschaftsforum in
davos der gesagt hat man müsste zum
status quo ante zurück das heißt also
dahin zurück was vor beginn des krieges
ausgangssituation war dass er so lohans
konto netz möglicherweise
an russland abgetreten werden müssten
auch die krim das vertritt eine 98
jährige ex diplomat und außenminister in
den usa im kongress ist es glaube ich
sehr eindeutig die überwältigende
mehrheit der abgeordneten und senatoren
beider parteien ist der festen
überzeugung man muss weiterhin alles tun
um der ukraine die möglichkeit zu geben
zu gewinnen in diesem krieg deswegen
eben auch die verabschiedung dieses
risikos risiken hilfspakets es geht
nicht alles an die ukraine aber doch ein
großer teil und allein 20 milliarden
dollar von den insgesamt 40 milliarden
dollar sollen eben in waffensysteme und
munition für die ukraine investiert
werden gehen wir gleich noch genauer
darauf ein halogen kann den putin auf
diesen westlichen ermüdungsbruch zählen
hat er möglicherweise den längeren atem
ich würde nicht von einem ermüdungsbruch
sprechen ich glaube auch es gibt eine
sehr differenzierte diskussion
insbesondere den usa werden sie in
deutschland doch sehr eindimensional
fokussiertes auf die fragen der
waffenlieferung und ähnliches mehr und
es gibt also eine ganze reihe von fragen
die vollkommen unklar sind was bedeutet
zum beispiel ein sieg und ich glaube
dass das was die kissinger heutige heute
gesagt hat wahrscheinlich eine
realpolitische perspektive eröffnet und
es muss eigentlich im vordergrund stehen
das interesse den krieg schnellstmöglich
zu beenden zu für die kleine günstigen
bedingungen
und wenn man dieses ziel nicht verfolgt
sondern sich einstellt auf einen langen
krieg dann bedeutet das dass man
einerseits zynisch über die kosten und
natürlich über die vielen menschlichen
opfer hinweg geht und gleichzeitig auch
natürlich die eskalation risiken aus dem
blick lässt
hat der westen eigentlich eine strategie
wenn er der ukraine massiv mit waffen
hilft wie das jetzt gerade passiert
diese waffen hilfe ist ja angelaufen
steckt da eine strategie dahinter oder
anders gefragt ist im westen klar wohin
das führt
ja also eher den messen in freundlichen
start hin dass führt wenn man das
unterlässt die ukrainische
rüstungsindustrie ist er weitgehend
zukommt und zerstört die die waffen und
die munition die die ukraine während
dass der vorlauf ist dieses krieges das
war ja vorher nicht frieden sondern es
war der kriege um wasser hergestellt hat
oder gebraucht hat ja dass er selber
hergestellt wenn man die
waffenlieferungen abschneidet dann geht
die ukraine militärisch unter so einfach
ist die sache ist so lang man geliefert
kann sie überleben
die die frage dann natürlich wo es endet
die ist zur zeit meiner ansicht nach
auch noch verfrüht die die russische
offensive in don was macht fortschritte
um sie werden jetzt ist jetzt die lage
enorm kritisch
wir wissen eigentlich nicht so zu sagen
wie sich das über den sommer
weiterentwickelt russland verfolgt eine
politik der annexion in den in den
besetzten gebieten
selbst wenn es also wie das in
deutschland aufgefordert wird er zu
einem waffenstillstand allem ins drei
kommen würde minsk zwei hatte den krieg
nicht beendet sondern hat ihn nur in
einer phase der abkühlung und
vorbereitung überführt aus dem jetzt
dieser krieg entstanden ist ein minsk
rey abkommen wenn man schreit so schnell
wie möglich beenden würde den krieg
nicht beenden es würde den krieg nur
verlängern das würde den russen eine
chance geben den krieg dann zu besseren
bedingungen neu entfachen zugleich
ansätzen waffenstillstand ist es nicht
so dass waffenstillstand fast das
einzige ist was man mit putin aushandeln
kann weil alles andere kann man sich
doch gar nicht vorstellen dass das mit
putin in irgendwelche verhandlungen also
oder mit dem system putin in
irgendwelche verhandlungen mündet
also waffenstillstände wurden mit putin
in syrien genug verhandelt und viele und
die meisten auch gebrochen
waffenstillstände wurden mit putin in
ukrainischen verhandelt und sie haben
nicht gehalten mit putin kann man
insoweit verhandeln wenn man die realen
gegebenheiten am boden so zu seinen
ungunsten verändert eine dass er sich
gezwungen sieht
anzuerkennen was fakt ist und da ist das
problem sowohl in syrien als auch jetzt
in der ukraine dass wir im westen auf
treu und glauben hoffen aber am boden
nicht die militärischen gegebenheiten
schaffen die aus russischer sicht
unumstößlich sind und hier müssen wir
die reihenfolge umkehren zuerst die
militärischen gegebenheiten und dann
wird ein frieden folgen das heißt
militärischen gegebenheiten in dem
zusammenhang in dem zusammenhang muss
die russische armee im feld geschlagen
werden in ihm sind dass sie so
unbrauchbar ist dass sie auf jahre
hinaus eine fortsetzung dieses angriffes
nicht mehr durchführen kann frau
veronika haben ja gehört henry kissinger
langjähriger us-außenminister ist zwar
schon 98 jahre alt äußert sich immer
noch ist ja ein typischer vertreter der
realpolitik der sagt den status quo ante
also soll prinzip zu werden wie vor dem
24 februar ist das den ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer zuzumuten ich fand auch
wissen dass gerade zitiert hat den herrn
kissinger von anfang des krieges und ich
glaube das ist ein existenzieller punkt
der in ganz vielen katzen nicht so ganz
klar ist herr grasser brachte es gerade
an dieser krieg findet nichts seit dem
24 februar statt und wenn herr kissinger
meint dass wir zum status quo von anfang
des krieges zurückkehrten sollten dann
sprechen wir davon dass sie die krim
nicht mehr annektiert ist das auch in
den bars die gebiete wieder der ukraine
in unter der kontrolle der ukraine sind
was das bis das wäre der anfang des
krieges also wenn wir das zitieren und
das auseinandernehmen dann wird er das
die richtige auslegung
lüdeking wenn ich henry kissinger das
richtig verstanden habe meinte er
allerdings den status quo ante vor dem
24 februar nämlich war ja da auch schon
don bass und die creme von russland
besetzt also das heißt das dass
praktisch bei russland bleibt ist das
wirklich realistisch dass die ukraine
sich auf einen solchen frieden einlassen
in der die territoriale integrität der
ukraine nicht wie der faktisch nicht
wieder hergestellt wird also den bass
und grint blieben ja unter zumindest
unter russischer kontrolle
kann sich die ukraine auf so etwas
einlassen oder ist umgekehrt das
westliche ziel diese integrität
wiederherzustellen
die frühe
illusorisch
es ist interessant mal einen blick
zurückzuwerfen auf den 29 märz dieses
jahres und damals hat er auch
präsident selensky von einem kompromiss
gesprochen der aus mehreren teilen
bestand unter anderem hatte er auch
wenn man so will eine abtretung der
krim wie auch ein sonderstatus für den
bass
ins spiel gebracht nehmen auch natürlich
einer neutralisierung der ukraine davon
ist jetzt ukrainischer seite nicht mehr
gerät die rede weil man vielleicht auch
ermutigt ist durch die bisherigen
erfolge die man auf dem schlachtfeld
errungen hat allerdings muss man doch
glaube ich realpolitisch insofern finde
ich der die position die kissinger
dargestellt hat eine realpolitische muss
man davon ausgehen dass man zu einem
interessenausgleich zwang und tourismus
kommen muss und da bietet sich 1 1
ausgleich an der zumindest jetzt für die
nächste zeit frieden schafft so dass
jetzt die zehntausenden von toten die
man zu beklagen hat jetzt nicht auch
noch in der zukunft
einkalkulieren muss und man muss ja sich
auch mal
wahr werden was sind die kosten dieses
krieges nicht in dunklen geld und
sonstigen wirtschaftlichen rückschlägen
sondern auch gerade an menschenleben und
heute gerade ist ja auch in davos sehr
groß darüber gesprochen worden und auch
in g 7 treffen was die kosten sind für
die dritte welt für lieferungen menschen
die man da zum klagen ich bin nur der
meinung man muss also da ein blick
zumindest für den augen für für das
realpolitisch erreichbar waren es ist
auch ganz klar wir sind in einem ganz
merkwürdige dilemma und das hat ja auch
habermas sehr schön da das wäre
einerseits sicherstellen müssen dass die
eu keine auf dem schlachtfeld nicht
verliert was ein
fataler präzedenzfall wäre auf der einen
seite auf der anderen seite gibt es aber
auch kein spiel für ein taktisches
pokern wir müssen wie ich anfangs sagt
aus meiner sicht zumindest dafür sorge
tragen dass der konflikt so schnell wie
möglich beendet wird und
auch zur bedingung wenn er erzählt haben
und musik darf ich daran
dass ich eine kurze nachfrage stellen
sagen also die kosten und die opfer des
krieges nur wenn was ja häufig
befürchtet wird dann doch zugeständnis
an putin gemacht wenn eine windelweiche
vereinbarung wäre ja die einladung zur
nächsten konflikt mit vielleicht noch
größeren opfern und noch größeren kosten
ich glaube der putin ist ein
sehr scharf kalkulieren der
machtpolitiker der ganz genau weiß dass
sein sein
seine rechnung nicht aufgegangen ist
ganz im gegenteil wenn man sich das mal
anschaut russland hat schon jetzt eine
fatale niederlage erleiden müssen und er
will jetzt wahrscheinlich weil er auch
in einer historischen mission sich sieht
weil er auch natürlich an seinem job
hängt als präsident der russischen
föderation jetzt nicht aufgeben und will
jedenfalls ein
frieden nur zu bestimmten bedingungen
keinen gegner auf leider nicht dass er
bereit wäre das wäre auch für die
russische bevölkerung und auch für sein
regime nicht zu vermitteln als erfolg
den er ja präsentieren will wenn jetzt
auch als ergebnis dieses krieges die
krim abgetreten würde und auch der
donbass ist natürlich eine sache die
jetzt von der ukraine nicht erwartet
werden kann dass sich auf diese gebiete
verzichtet allerdings wird es auch
natürlich einen prozess geben ost putin
und ich bin sicher dass man
einen neuen ansatz dann machen muss um
auch und das ist auch für mich ganz klar
wir können nicht einfach die russische
für aktion aus euro darf man dem moment
über
russlands angewiesen
ist welche zugeständnisse machte oder
wild die ukrainische bevölkerung
eigentlich machen will sie welche machen
selensky kollegah auch der botschafter
der ukraine in berlin gegen einen
anderen eindruck sie sind in der tat ja
in einer schwierigen situation
das ist eine sehr interessante frage und
ich fühle mich in einen dieser situation
um ehrlich zu sein wir haben
2014/2015 genauer gesagt mit
realpolitischen thesen argumentiert wir
haben das aus allen podien in
deutschland gehört wir haben das aus
allen podien in europa gehört es hier
bitte realpolitisch bleiben sollten dass
wir auch was könnten wir jetzt noch mal
anbieten als auch als ukraine erinnern
was wäre denn noch etwas anzubieten an
russland und ich denke wir sind an einem
punkt wo wir auch wirklich darauf
bestehen können dass es damit reicht
etwas anzubieten weil wir genug
angeboten haben wir haben in den letzten
acht jahren wir waren in minsk ein
prozess wie waren in minsk zwei prozess
ukraine hat genug zugeständnisse gemacht
und ich frage mich was wären die
indikatoren die uns einfach zeigen
würden dass russland bereit ist zum
dialog wir haben in diesen acht jahren
gesehen dass alles was aus der dawes aus
dem kreml kam auch von der russischen
führung kann das waren repression eigene
bevölkerung der depression der
opposition sogar die deutschen sphinx
die
zivilgesellschaftlichen dialog gefördert
haben wurden zur ausländischen agenten
im jahr im mai gesinnt sind genau vor
einem jahr im mai 21 also ausländischen
agenten erklärt und ich frage mich
persönlich wie ist das warum sind wir
immer noch an diesem punkt dass wir
immer noch sagen was können wir anbieten
das bloß mit russland kein dialog ab
recht gut da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche lösungsansätze mrt
wissen unter anderem vom us
verteidigungsminister lloyd austin der
gesagt hat man müsse jetzt als
konsequenz dieses räuberischen und
verbrecherischen überfalls auf die
ukraine die angriffs fähigkeit russlands
so schwächen dass dieses land in zukunft
keine nachbarn und da gibt es ja viele
in russischer nachbarschaft mehr
bedrohen kann wir reden ja von der den
realistischen szenarien die der westen
gerade entwickelt mit dem ukraine krieg
wieder ausgehen soll ist dass in den usa
eine meinung die andere auch vertreten
versucht die usa durch waffenlieferungen
durch militär strategie durch andere
maßnahmen bis hin zu
geheimdienstaktivitäten genau diese
schwächen zu erreichen
ich glaube ein eindeutiges ja das signal
dass hier letzte woche durch den
kongress gesetzt worden ist es ein sehr
klares nämlich dass die amerikaner an
der seite der ukraine stehen werden bis
die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt und
zwar nicht im sinne von notwendigerweise
russland komplett zu vertreiben sondern
in erster linie dafür zu sorgen dass
während auf der ukrainischen seite keine
ermüdung was waffen und munition angeht
eintreten wird weil man eben eifrig
weiter liefern wird und das auch von den
verbündeten erwartet aber dass auf der
anderen seite auf der russischen seite
ermüdung eintritt und bis dahin eben die
ukraine die chance haben stück für stück
meter für meter kilometer für kilometer
verloren gegangenes territorium wieder
zurückzuerobern so wie das jahr rund um
krakau in den letzten tagen schon
einigermaßen gelungen ist also die
amerikaner stehen politisch jedenfalls
wie eine eins und die leser wird
vielleicht sehr deutlich wenn man liest
dass mitt romney ein republikanischer
senator übrigens auch gerade in der new
york times geschrieben hat der hat
natürlich davor gewarnt wir müssen
vorsichtig sein dass es nicht zu einer
nuklearen der eskalation kommt aber das
bedeutet so sagt er ganz klar nicht im
umkehrschluss dass er dafür plädiert man
muss irgendwelche kompromisse machen
sondern man muss dafür sorgen dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen kann und
er bemüht ein bild das sehr grässlich
klingt er sagt wenn wir putin
entgegenkommen und ihm etwas geben dann
wäre das so als würde man einen
kannibalen bezahlen nur dafür dass man
am ende trotzdem von ihm aufgefressen
wird das klingt sehr drastisch ist aber
eine haltung die im amerikanischen
kongress
mit großer großer mehrheit quer durch
die parteien vertreten wird und die usa
werden glaube ich dass weiter
vorantreiben in den nächsten wochen
sicherlich auch aus allein dem grund
weil sie diesen konflikt als ein ich sag
mal beispiel für den großen konflikt
zwischen liberalen demokratien und
autoritarismus sehen und jedes
zurückweichen vor putin am ende auch ein
signal an china wäre quasi zu sagen okay
china könnte auch zum beispiel den
taiwan einmarschieren ohne dass es
entsprechende konsequenzen fürchten
lässt aber immer weil sie das gerade
sagen mit china ist denn nicht die
gefahr groß für die usa dass sich ihre
militärischen und politischen
kapazitäten über den
beiden ist ja gerade in asien unterwegs
auf eine ermutigung stour in sachen teil
waren sagen wir werden euch auch
militärisch helfen sollte china
angreifen das hat ja noch eine ganz
andere dimension
wir reden ja darüber kann der westen
kann auch die usa dieses versprechen
jetzt in bezug auf die ukraine
durchhalten wenn der krieg länger dauert
wenn er massive einsätze erforderten
möglicherweise noch andere globale
fronten entstehen die frage ob die usa
nicht irgendwann mal sagen wir haben es
doch ein bisschen übernommen es gibt
beispiele in der amerikanischen
geschichte wo man sich dann ziemlich
schnell ich zurückgezogen hat
also es ist ganz klar dass die usa das
nicht alleine können auf keinen fall an
in verschiedenen regionen der welt
gleichzeitig im grunde um der einzige
sein der diese militärische macht
projiziert deswegen brauchen sie die
verbündeten und um diese verbündeten
zusammenzuhalten ist es extrem wichtig
aus der lesart des weißen hauses dass
man selber mit extrem gutem beispiel
voran schreitet also dieses dieses
commitment wie das hier heißt oder
dieses all-in zu signalisieren dass man
über monate vielleicht über jahre der
ukraine weiter eben diese unterstützung
geben wird damit andere mitmachen und
das erwarten die usa auch von den
anderen der nächste schritt wird ja zum
beispiel seien ende juni bei nato gipfel
zu beraten wo man in osteuropa
langfristig truppen stationiert wo man
feste stützpunkte schafft beispielsweise
rumänien oder auch der tschechischen
republik in polen und anderswo und das
werden die amerikaner nicht alleine
können sondern sie brauchen die
unterstützung das geld die ressourcen
und auch das personal spricht die
soldaten anderer nato partner um dies
langfristig zu tun und deswegen glaube
ich dass dieses signal von letzter woche
mit der entscheidung im kongress schon
ein klares ist auch an die verbündeten
wir müssen weiter vorangehen und können
nicht zurückweichen weil das auch an
anderen ecken der erde dem autoritär
ismus dann wieder wasser auf die mühle
geben könnte der kessel wir sind noch in
der abteilung die westlichen ziele der
unterstützung der ukraine und wie
realistisch sie sind da gibt es ja auch
eine weitere forderung oder eine
weiteres strategisches ziel nämlich die
ukraine für zukünftige mögliche
konflikte mit russland militärisch zu
ertüchtigen dass eine solche invasion
nicht mehr möglich ist nicht nur
russland schwächen sondern die ukraine
militärisch zu ertüchtigen
waffenlieferungen ist das eine
rüstungskooperation im großen stil wird
da schon angeboten zwischen europäischen
rüstungsfirmen der ukraine
sicherheitsgarantien ist das ein
realistisches ziel
das ist ein langfristig ist hier das
muss ja nicht nur mit der ukraine
gemacht werden es gibt auch andere
nachbarstaaten die durch russland
bedroht sind es gibt im pazifischen raum
nachbarstaaten die durch china bedroht
sind mit den teilwahlen schaut sehr eng
auf das was hier geschieht und ja das
wird das wird nach dem krieg auch noch
weiter am tablett stehen
wir sind wieder in einer situation wie
zur zeit des kalten krieges wo die
militärische lage ausschlaggebend ist
für die politische und soziale
sicherheit von staaten und wenn uns an
den kalten krieg erinnern schweden oder
auch zum beispiel jugoslawien nach dem
split zwischen
stalin und tito haben auch damals
amerikanische militär insel bekommen
haben auch damals eine verteidigung
kooperationen rüstungs kooperationen
wenn man denkt an saab oder amboss mit
dem westen unterhalten also all das ist
ja eigentlich nichts neues jeder der ein
bisschen älter ist kann sich ja noch an
die an die zeiten erinnern
was wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben
was westliche ziele sind also großen
raus aus der ukraine russland schwächen
ukraine stärken oder ertüchtigen sind
sich denn die westlichen staaten also
die nato-staaten da einig in dieser
strategie oder gibt es da auch andere
die sagen also das ist wir uns ein
bisschen zu weit gefasst dass kriege nur
ähnlichen
also
der großteil der nato staaten sind sich
einig dann gibt es natürlich noch
starten wie
erdogans türkei und das umgang von
viktor orban wo man mit der russischen
ideologie die auch durch putin auf den
tisch gelegt würde einige
berührungspunkte hat oder oder momente
das gefallen findet wenn man ja wenn man
ja sich anschaut wie putin diesen krieg
gerechtfertigt hat wie putin seine
ukraine politik rechtfertigt hat dann
spricht er aus allen ecken und enden
karl schmidt aus ihm heraus wenn man
sich die ich habe in seiner rede am 21
februar die sozusagen kurz vor
kriegsbeginn gefragt wurde habe ich kann
schmidt die völkerrechtliche großraum
ordnung am tisch liegen habe dann hab
mit geschaut in karl schmid und putin
jetzt steht mit seiner rede das war eins
zu eins das und es gibt weitere staaten
die sich als großmächte sehen die
großräume für sich beanspruchen wenn das
angefangen in serbien wo man busse noch
nicht aufgegeben hat und im kosovo noch
nicht aufgegeben hat angefangen in der
türkei wo man ein neo osmanisches wo man
in syrien mit den kurden hier auch noch
sozusagen die gebiets- fragen noch nicht
ganz gegessen hat und diese diese
möchtegern regionen finden in russland 1
5 vorbild und die finden an russland
gefallen und an der russischen politik
gefallen
und es gibt natürlich dann auch
politische kräfte innerhalb vor allen
dingen deutschlands und frankreichs die
das ähnlich sehen und die aus ähnlichen
motivation gründen die zwar nicht
federführend sind wie madame le pen in
frankreich
irgendwie gewisse stimmen in deutschland
die aber vor der inhalte mindestens in
italien die die nationale politik so zu
verbessern dass eine klare westliche
position ihren traum mit russland eine
andere europäische ordnung zu
verwirklichen nicht ganz unmöglich
machen und das macht viele diskussionen
in nato-staaten recht fische problem und
jetzt geht in der sendung auch um die
verlässlichkeit des westens das was man
zugesagt hat an unterstützung dass das
auch tatsächlich dann eintritt ein
wichtiges element sind die sanktionen
des westens gegen russland da gibt es
fünf sanktionspaket die möglicherweise
bald ein sechstes das sogenannte
ölembargo
sind die ausreichen diese sanktion aus
ukrainischer sicht was der westen bisher
umgesetzt hat und was deutschland die
auch mit projekt ich glaube ausweichend
können wir das nicht nennen weil im
wagen und gas embargo über noch im raum
stehen hoch umstritten auch in
deutschland auch interessant war schon
das so hoch umstritten ist wir wissen
dass mit dem mit den gast
gaslieferungen und dem einkauf und gas
auch die russische armee auch
unterstützt wird das ist ein ganz
wichtiger und entscheidender punkt dass
dadurch auch die russische wirtschaft
erhalten bleibt und das wäre ein
wirklich wichtiger punkt dass
einzuführen das öl und gas embargo
deswegen auf ihre frage zu sagen nein
die sanktionen reichen nicht aus in der
schule die wir derzeit haben auch mit
der nichtnominierung der gast schon bank
also die geschäfte werden trotzdem noch
finden noch statt und sanktionen werden
umgang und wir wissen warum warum es
nicht greift töging bei einem möglichen
waffenstillstand oder
verhandlungsfrieden
friedensverhandlungen man nimmt das
heute ja eigentlich fast ungern in den
mund welche rolle sollen die sanktionen
denn da spielen als druckmittel
gegenüber putin soll die aufrecht
erhalten bleiben denn putin wird ja ein
zäher verhandlungspartner sein wenn es
überhaupt zu diesen verhandlungen kommt
ich sehe im augenblick dass man wenn man
so will ein dimensional auf
konfrontation auf die militärischen
mittel setzt und natürlich auch die
wirtschaftssanktionen als wirtschafts
kriegs maßnahmen anwenden das ist
richtig so denn das ist ganz klar
putin hat einen verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg angefangen und er darf
damit nicht durchkommen auf der anderen
seite was mir aber allerdings fehlt was
immer auch eigentlich bestandteil seit
den 60er jahren der nato-politik war war
eine diplomatische begleitung der
versuch der auslotung wie man den krieg
beenden kann und dieses muss eigentlich
auch geschehen und da muss ich sagen
sind wahrscheinlich die europäischen
staaten nicht zeit des fraktions rechnen
aus auggen putin sondern das muss auf
großer ebene durch die usa geschehen und
wenn es da eine möglichkeit gibt und da
will ich wieder sagen dass man in krieg
der jetzt ja sehr günstig steht für die
ukraine ob das in den nächsten monaten
noch immer so der fall sein wird man
abwarten müssen
immerhin hat sich ja zum beispiel die
große sportnation im süden der ukraine
schon fest gesetzt und versucht das auch
zur offizieren dann sollte man das jetzt
tun und deshalb finde ich gibt es auch
in den usa durchaus ernst zu nehmende
stimmen von links die dafür votieren
jetzt die chance zu ergreifen um
auszuloten ob es die möglichkeit für
einen frieden gibt für einen
waffenstillstand der natürlich begleitet
werden muss von einer
friedenslösung die diplomatisch
ausgelotet diesen gedanken können wir ja
gleich nach washington weiter leiten
elmar das würde ja aber bedeuten wenn
jetzt die usa sozusagen als einziges
land auf augenhöhe oder das von putin
auf augenhöhe akzeptiert wird da
eingreifen soll mit
friedensverhandlungen
dann müsste ja wir haben es vorhin
besprochen joe biden ja eigentlich
häufiger die new york times lesen wo
eben drin steht dass man eben dass
dieser krieg nicht irgendwie mal in die
irre führt aber nicht zu gewinnen ist
ist gibt es da auch als sozusagen
subkutan ansätze
da zu einem gespräch mit russland so
schwer das ist zu kommen
also ich glaube erst mal gilt das auch
im weißen haus will jeder vermeiden dass
man in einem unmittelbaren krieg mit
russland reingezogen wird sieht man
übrigens an der debatte die gerade ja
hinter den kulissen stattfindet
inwieweit man spezialkräfte der us
streitkräfte nach kiew entsendet um die
botschaft doch zu schützen oder dass
vielleicht lieber nicht macht weil es
könnte so dargestellt werden als wäre
das dann ein kriegseintritt der usa so
da ist das weiße haus schon sehr
vorsichtig aber vergangene woche hat ja
leute aus den nicht leute aus dem
entschuldigung general mark milli der
chef der des generalstabes hier im
pentagon sein portal in russland
angerufen general gerasimov und hat mit
ihm gesprochen über was genau wissen wir
nicht aber wir sehen das auch als ein
signal dass das erste gespräch seit
beginn des krieges gewesen auf dieser
ich sag mal augenhöhe dass man geführt
hat dass das schon ein signal ist an
moskau dass man erkunden will wie sieht
es denn eigentlich aus und man muss
sagen dass gleichzeitig natürlich der
druck hoch gehalten werden kann jeder
ich sagte es vorhin schon einmal jeder
quadratkilometer der zurückerobert wird
durch ukrainische streitkräfte ist eine
kleine niederlage für wladimir putin und
die russische armee und wenn finnland
und schweden mitglieder der nato werden
dann sind das niederlagen und je länger
ist im grunde genommen dauert desto mehr
werden sich diese arten von niederlagen
für wladimir putin so soll jedenfalls
signal ihres vorschicken sein
aufsummieren so dass man hier klar sagt
der ball liegt im grunde genommen im
bereich von wladimir putin er muss sich
entscheiden kontakt aufzunehmen um zu
signalisieren dass es
verhandlungsbereitschaft gibt ob er das
tut darüber ist man hier in washington
sehr skeptisch aber man ist nicht bereit
von amerikanischer seite aus
irgendwelche angebote zu machen schon
gar nicht über den kopf der ukraine
hinweg man hat immer sehr klar gemacht
wenn es ein angebot von der westlichen
seite gäbe dann müsste das unmittelbar
von wolodimir selensky kommen es gibt ja
eine rote linie die der westen selbst
gezogen hat kein angriff kein direktes
eingreifen in der ukraine krieg eine
flugverbotszone und so weiter gibt es in
eine art von waffenlieferungen an
qualität und quantität die auch die
ukraine massiv ausrüsten dritten die
diese eskalation schwelle aus russischer
sicht überschreitet das dann auch
unterhalb eines kriegseintritt in der
ukraine wo die waffenlieferungen so
massiv werden dass putin irgendwie
reagieren muss oder provoziert wird
die restlichen entschuldigung
vielleicht atomraketen aber nicht wie
weit ich jetzt gar nicht das ist ja die
frage ob er so ein bluff war
die
russland russland droht jetzt natürlich
der nato wegen finnland und wegen
schweden und so weiter aber die
geschichte für russland ist ja die man
ist jetzt mit der ukraine gebunden und
man hat jetzt jenseits von drohungen und
provokationen nicht die kräfte andere
fronten aufzureißen also auch putin bei
all seinen überlegungen muss man mit
denken wenn ich den nächsten schritt in
die richtung wo endet das für mich wo
endet dann die eskalation und deshalb
ist trotz aller natürlich rhetorik die
aufbauscht er in der gegenwärtigen
situation wo die armee ebenso gebunden
ist in der ukraine
nicht nicht an einer eskalation jetzt
ging als selbst wenn er das findet was
die nato da treibt und dagegen
protestiert er kann es dagegen
militärisch nicht vorgehen da fehlen
ihnen die kräfte dazu kann versuchen die
transporter in der ukraine dann zu
erwischen das versuchen sie die ganze
zeit aber darüber hinaus sind die hände
jetzt gebunden elmar theveßen
ja ich glaube es geht natürlich darum
dass die ukraine keine waffen bekommen
sollte mit der mit denen sie dann
unmittelbar auch russisches territorium
angreifen könnte das ist jetzt relativ
wenn man beispielsweise weitreichende
artilleriegeschütze hat dann kann man
natürlich auch russischen boden
erreichen und es gab ja auch einige
operationen in den vergangenen wochen
aber man liefert eben nicht alles es
wird glaube ich keine westlichen abrams
tanks aus den usa geben oder leopard 2
aus europa aber es wird bessere
artilleriegeschütze mit zielgenaueren
einrichtungen mit eben auch der besseren
munition geben und es wird auch damit
hat ich wenn ich's richtig verfolgt habe
dänemark jetzt angefangen haben raketen
zu liefern und die amerikaner werden
ähnliches tun um
dafür zu sorgen dass die ukraine eine
chance hat die seeblockade zu beenden
also tatsächlich wieder zugang zu helfen
und dann eben zur see zum schwarzen meer
zu gewährleisten also es werden auch
offensivere waffen geliefert werden in
den nächsten wochen aber die kante liegt
da wo es waffen sind die dann genutzt
werden könnten um auf russisches
territorium vorzudringen ich glaube
daran hat weder die nato noch allen
voran der stärkste nahtlos
bündnispartner die usa irgendein
interesse jetzt droht
er von einer anderen seite auch noch
gefahr für die ukraine was die
aufmerksamkeit angeht und die westliche
unterstützung der welt droht eine
massive wirtschaftliche rezession es
gibt in vielen ländern saftige
inflationsraten nicht nur aber auch
folgendes ukraine krieges wenn sich das
noch weiter verschlimmert könnte es sein
dass der westen wieder zu sehr auf sich
selbst zurückgeworfen wird er seine
interessen auch die interessen seiner
bevölkerung auch die unruhe in seiner
bevölkerung im auge hat statt den stadt
das leid der ukraine in diesem krieg
ich würde sehr gerne noch einen punkt
ansprechen weil sie haben vorhin von
waffe und dann gehe ich auf die frage an
wie sie fragt nach dem
waffenstillstand und hier möchte ich
wirklich ein punkt klar machen dass es
für die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer auch
menschen die in der ukraine kämpfen
keiner von denen wünscht sich mehr
waffenstillstand dass russland einfach
die ukraine nicht angreift weil die
ukraine ist in einer verteidigungsrede
die ukraine verteidigt das eigene land
und ich möchte dass dieser punkt auch
wirklich klar ist dass das land
angegriffen wurde und da sind keine zwei
kriegsparteien und es ist auch kein
ukraine krieg der aus meiner sicht
fehlerhafter weise immer in den medien
so genannt wird es ist ein russlands
krieg und wenn wir die sachen beim namen
nennen verändert auch das bewusstsein
der menschen weil damit dass wir das
ukraine krieg nennen ist ukraine immer
das problem aber die ukraine ist nicht
das land das das andere angegriffen hat
russland führt einen krieg gegen die
ukraine und da sind wir bei den punkt
der richtigen kommunikation bekomme ich
auf ihre frage
wie das für die europäische länder der
eu ist und vielleicht eine ermüdung auch
in den ländern der europäischen union
eintreten kann ich glaube ein
wesentlicher punkt in der tat ist die
kommunikation wie die sachen an die
bevölkerung auch kommuniziert werden wie
die sachen und politikerinnen
kommuniziert werden und
[Musik]
diese visionen oder auch inflationen die
gehen auch natürlich auch die korona
zeit zurück das ist jetzt nicht nur dass
der russlands krieg in europa russlands
krieg in der ukraine sondern auch was
wir ja schon mit folgen der korona krise
zu kämpfen haben und ich denke genau bei
diesen sachen ist eine geschlossene
geschlossenheit eu und verhandlungen und
auch entwicklung von bestimmten fonds
für die innen situation in der
europäischen union sehr sehr wichtig
das heißt wenn wir jetzt auf die auf die
ukraine sehen
wird das eine wird sich die krise im
prinzip auch zuspitzen nicht nur was den
krieg gegen die ukraine ich hatte das
vorhin auch ich habe vom überfall auf
die ukraine gesprochen also nicht um
krieg sagen meine ich natürlich wie
gegen die ukraine spitze vielfältig
vervielfältigt dass das problem ihres
landes
das sie jetzt auch wie gesagt wird dass
der west möglicherweise abgelenkt wird
durch interne durch interne krise ich
denke dass die ukraine für die werte
einfach der europäischen union aufsteht
und wenn der die westlichen mächte der
westen auch wegschauen das ist
gewissermaßen auch an eigenen werten die
kraft senkt sinken und die werte auch
nicht mehr so vertretbar durch die eu
sind und nochmal zu den
begrifflichkeiten natürlich ist das ich
verstehe weil sie meinen nicht verstehe
auch was in den medien steht aber wenn
das
das ist ja dasselbe wort im prinzip fast
so lang wie die ukraine also wenn man
unsere kriegt er sagt kann man auch
russland kriegt
sprachlichen bloß unsere wahrnehmen das
ist ganz simple sache das war vor acht
jahren haben wir darüber gesprochen dass
es krise ist konflikt das ist alles
nicht gewesen das ist schon gegessen
wenn man die folgen des ukraine kriegs
weiter denkt jetzt auch für den westen
ich habs gerade gesprochen
wirtschaftliche rezession
möglicherweise auch die stabilisierung
durch ausgelösten flüchtlingsströme wenn
kein getreide mehr nach afrika aus der
ukraine kommt
das hohe energiepreise jetzt entstehen
diese inflation das bedeutet ja eben
gerade die blockade des russischen
getreides oder des ukrainischen gebäudes
bedeutet ja auch viel für länder wie
afrika und asien da gibt es ja gerade
ein propagandakrieg zwischen dem westen
und russland wäre ich daran schuld ist
die sanktion des westens ist die
blockade der der ukrainischen helfen
könnte das dem westen noch auf die füße
fallen
der besten water sehr passiv muss man
auch sagen es gibt ja viele andere
argumente die der westen eigentlich
lange gegen russland hier in anderen
teilen der welt jetzt sich direkt mit
der ukraine keine berührungspunkte haben
ins gefecht führen hätte können der lose
ungarn russland mit einem klaren
drohungen wer so eine sache also die
stößt in vielen teilen der welt die der
nichtweiterverbreitungsvertrages
unterschrieben haben im guten glauben
dass sich nokia möchte gut benehmen auch
in der erfahrung dass sich die werte nun
sich damals ganz anders genommen hat als
dass russland heute tut das muss man ja
auch bei allen parallelen zum kalten
krieg
hervorkehren und und jetzt natürlich die
die getreide situation ist auch ist eine
andere die getreide situation wird sich
auch einen jahren also wenn es jetzt die
front so einfriert wie sie jetzt ist
wird sich auch in den nächsten jahren
oder jahrzehnten nicht bessern weil dann
ist nämlich das beste agrarland nämlich
direkte direktes frontgebiet das muss
man muss man auch dazu sagen eine
wirkliche verbesserung der
versorgungssicherheit würde sich da nur
geben wenn sich die fronten vor allem im
süden anders darstellen würde
und da da sind wir noch sind wir ja noch
entfernt darf ich doch in kurzen
nachsatz nur noch zwei minuten deswegen
würde ich rede gerne es gibt ja werden
bei den amerikanern es wird nicht alles
geliefert das
hauptproblem oder der sache ist
natürlich nicht die kann man nach
russland hinein schießen mit der
weitreichenden artillerie die jetzt
liefert kann man das eigentlich am
liebsten mit einem kampfpanzer erschießt
zwei bis vier kilometer weit die
geschichte ist natürlich die man schaut
im westen gebannt darauf erklärt punkten
formell den krieg schickt grund ruft
eine mobilmachung aus und die amerikaner
das aber auch die gespräche mit dem
russischen generalstabschef die
amerikaner müssen klar zu verstehen
geben dass die selbst auferlegten
begrenzungen die man sich jetzt bei
waffenlieferungen und so weit dass die
natürlich fallen würden wenn russland
das tun würde also hier hebt man sich
immer noch auch in sowohl bei den
sanktionen als auch bei den lieferungen
immer ein bisschen eskalation niveau auf
um zu sagen um den russen auch zu
signalisieren also wenn ihr aufgeht dann
ziehen wir nach also lasst es bleiben
ganz kurz wirklich nur noch eine minute
mit der bitte um eine kurze antwort auf
die fragen mrt wissen die haben erleben
jetzt eine blüte der distanz
atlantischen verhältnis ist dass niemand
mehr für möglich gehalten hätte nach
donald trump für das bleiben hat putin
den westen wieder zusammengebracht
also für die vorläufige zeit ja und das
wird sich als lackmustest an später
zeigen wie weit man gegen auch gegen
china oder china gegenüber eben eine
klare kante aus europa gemeinsam mit
amerika und den g-7-staaten zu hören
bekommt aber ehrlicherweise das ganze
ist auch auf amerikanischer seite fragil
je nachdem wie die kongresswahlen
ausgehen oder in drei jahren die
präsidentschaftswahl also es ist eine
phase in der die allianz wieder
zusammengefunden hat ob es langfristig
hält das wird man sehen benötigen ganz
kurz bitte nur eine ganz kurze antwort
osze 20 früher botschafter gewesen
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa muss die viel
stärker bei der bei den friedensprozess
in der ukraine einbezogen werden
dazu hat sich nicht die möglich es ist
jetzt wirklich eine phase wo man ganz
entschieden auch auf die usa setzen muss
und wo auch die europäer versuchen
müssen hilfreich zu sein um einen weg zu
finden aus dieser aus diesen krieg der
jetzt fortgesetzt wird und droht
einzufrieren gut und das ist nicht gut
klare antwort ich bedanke mich bei
natalia panitzke bei gustav gräßel bei
rüdiger lüdeking und bei einem kollegen
elmar theveßen zugestellt aus washington
liebe zuschauer morgen in der phoenix
runde der titel 100 milliarden und jetzt
das dilemma der bundeswehr hat natürlich
auch mit viel mit der ukraine zu tun
bleiben müssen bei uns
[Musik]